have you ever thought about killing  Nicole million-dollar question is Cuba  do you think he did it or he didn't do  it I came to an agreement with myself  that I would keep an open mind in terms  of what the director asked me to do take  after take right and I kind of created  this shorthand where he would come on to  me to go okay in this take I want him to  be guilty and let's take I want him to  be innocent and frustrated by what's  going on whatever you decide to do  whether you're with me or not you got to  know this every day on the set I would  go through a range of emotions because I  would find that facts about things that  happened that I thought I knew to be  true that warrant and every day I would  go from his innocence to his guilt it's  been a really emotional roller coaster  Oh Jay did it not guilty not say it  maybe be guilty not guilty  oh just running cuz he's innocent he's a  Batman being haunted by the phonies